so I think a lot about the contrast
between banality and wonderful between
disengagement and radiant ecstasy
between being unaffected by the
here-and-now being absolutely ravished
emotionally by it and I think one of the
problems were human beings is mental
habits once we create a comfort zone we
rarely step outside of that comfort zone
but the consequence of that is a
phenomenon known as hedonic adaptation
over stimulation - the same kind of
thing the same stimuli again and again
and again renders said stimuli invisible
your brain is already mapped it in its
own head and you no longer literally
have to be engaged by that we have eyes
yet see not ears that hear not and
hearts that neither feel nor understand
there's a great book called the
wondering brain that says that one of
the ways that we elicit wonder is by
scrambling the self temporarily so that
the world can seep in Henry Miller says
in a blade of grass when given proper
attention becomes an infinitely
magnificent world in itself you know
Darwin said attention if sudden enclosed
graduates in surprise and this into
astonishment and this is just stupefied
amazement
that's what rapture is that's what
illumination is that's what that sort of
infant comprehending ah that human
beings love so much and so how do we do
that how do we mess with our perceptual
apparatus in order to have the kind of
emotional and aesthetic experience from
life that we render most meaningful
because we all know those moments are
there those are the moments that will
make final cut
only in these moments we experience
afresh the hardly bearable ecstasy of
direct energy exploding on our nerve
endings this is the rev static ecstatic
bursting forth of awe that expands our
perceptual parameters beyond all
previous limits and we literally have to
reconfigure our mental models of the
world in order to assimilate the beauty
of that download that is what it means
to keep inspired the Greek root of the
term is to breathe in take it in which
fit the universe through our brains and
it comes out in the form of nothing less
than poetry we have a responsibility to
all